NARRATOR:
This is the shark tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes of
getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
Go!
GIRL: Go!
Come on, let's go!
Let's go!
[ laughter ]
NARRATOR: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll
walk away with nothing.
Americans are being watched!
Whoa.
Well, I want to be filthy rich
like everyone else.
We think the company
is worth $6 million.
Oh!
Wow.
NARRATOR: If the sharks hear
a great idea...
You could use it
as home plate
in your cockroach
baseball league.
...They're ready to invest
using their own money.
Wow!
And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
I'd like to make you
an interesting offer.
Robert's offer is effectively
radioactive waste.
Oh, man.
So, are you saying no?
CUBAN: Hell, no.
Are you kidding?
He's smarter than that.
Robert, I want you and Lori
to work together.
Hang on, my friend.
I can't do it.
It would be a stupid move
for me.
No, no,
you guys got to work it out.
Wow!
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu,
with over $6 billion
in retail sales to date.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents and
has launched over 300 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban, notorious
billionaire entrepreneur,
tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
My name is Thomas Hill.
Come here, boo.
I live in Anthem, Arizona,
with my wife, our daughter,
and our twin boys.
Started playing football
in high school,
and I quickly noticed
that that was my ticket
out of the rough area
that I grew up in.
Growing up was a struggle.
My father was never around,
and my brother and I
would watch our mom fight
to put food on the table.
I had the opportunity to go
to Kansas State University,
and I was selected
by the Green Bay Packers in 2004
as a free-agent tight end.
I had a college injury
that was hindering me,
and it ultimately led
to me being released
by the Green Bay Packers.
Are you guys ready?!
Yeah!
All right,
let's go, let's go, let's go!
I wasn't about to let
being released by the NFL
kill my dreams.
I've taken
a unique business model,
mixed it
with my athletic background,
and created something
that allows kids to have fun,
be fit, and stay engaged.
Go, go, go!
There's no doubt in my mind
that the sharks are gonna love
my product.
They're entrepreneurs
just like me,
and I hope the sharks can see
what my product can do
for all kids across the country
and give me a deal.
[ whistle blows ]
Hello, sharks.
My name is Thomas Hill.
I'm the founder and creator
of Bounce Boot Camp.
I'm here seeking $30,000
in exchange for 20% equity
in my company.
Sharks,
we face a huge challenge today.
1 in 3 children are obese,
and that number
only continues to grow.
But, sharks, we have a business
here that can change that.
We have a unique system here
called Bounce Boot Camp.
Bounce boot camp
is the first and only
mobile company of its kind
that combines the fun of
inflatable obstacle courses,
slides, and castles, into a fun
fitness program for kids.
How I came about this idea --
my lovely daughter, Jada, here
actually invited me to bounce in
a bounce-house castle with her
one day.
After bouncing
for roughly three minutes,
I quickly found
my heart rate was up,
my legs were burning,
I was sweating like crazy.
I thought,
"Man, a fit guy like me?"
whoa.
Right then, sharks, it hit me.
How awesome would it be
to create a fitness program
for kids
all based around
using the inflatables?
That night, sharks,
I created Bounce Boot Camp.
These young junior generals
would like to show you
that fitness really can be fun.
Is that all right?
Yep.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Are you guys ready?
Yeah!
Sweet, let's do it!
Let's do it.
Kira, you're right here
on the battle ropes.
Andrew Morgan,
plank one position.
Jada, you're in the squats.
Here we go. Let's show 'em
how we make it look good.
Ready, set, go!
Come on, Andrew Morgan.
Get through there.
Beat that ground up, Kira.
Wow!
Beat that ground up.
Let's go, let's go.
Dang.
Let's go.
Yeah, let's go, Jada.
Get through there.
Kira, give me the up-downs.
All right.
Give me the up-downs, Kira.
You didn't even know
you had abs, did you?
[ laughs ]
That looks good right there.
Come on, Jada, finish.
Three...Two...One.
Oh, my God.
Look how long he's doing that.
Ahh, great job, guys!
That's what I'm talking about.
Good workout.
Nicely done, guys.
We can put a Bounce Boot Camp
in every single city
across the country.
Which one of you --
or all of you --
are ready to help me
bounce out obesity?
In fact, which one of you --
or a couple of you --
would like to come down
and have a little bit of fun
with fitness?
There we go. Let's go.
You can take your jackets off.
Come on, Rob.
This is you all day.
All right, I want to try.
Come on.
Get in there.
I want to see Daymond
do a plank.
Right, I'm gonna have you
right here, Mr. Mark Cuban,
in a plank one.
yes, sir.
You're gonna race
this young gentleman to the end,
touch the ground, and then
you're gonna come back.
You want me to get through
that thing?
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah.
Ready, set, go!
Come on, Andrew Morgan!
Come on, Andrew Morgan,
let's go!
Let's go! Let's go! Let's go!
Get through there!
Look at that.
He's already coming back.
Where you at, Cuban?
Where you at, Mark Cuban?
[ laughter ]
Come on, Cuban.
You can do it, baby!
Nicely done.
Nicely done, my man.
Daymond, I'll take you.
You guys are gonna be
in a plank one position.
Plank. Come on, now.
Don't cheat. There we go.
Ready, set, go!
GIRL: Go!
Come on, let's go!
Let's go!
[ laughter ]
JOHN: Get off me!
Get off me!
No cheating, no cheating.
No cheating.
Go, Daymond.
Come on, let's go!
Daymond's got the lead!
Come on, Daymond!
[ cheering ]
[ laughter ]
Nicely done.
That was harder than it looked.
It was.
Great job, great job, great job.
Yay, Daymond!
All right!
Kid signs up, they get a bounce
boot camp dog tag like this.
Here we go.
That was a lot of fun.
Great job, great job.
Thank you.
I think I ripped my trousers,
but I'm good.
[ laughter ]
Great job.
CUBAN:
I want a rematch!
Great job.
We can get that for you.
Tom,
tell us about the business.
How do you make money
with an inflatable boot camp?
So, our company
is a mobile company.
We have a 6x12 trailer.
It's a business in a box.
So, you show up with the
trailer, you blow it up.
We blow it up.
Each camp has a different
configuration of inflatables,
so one day you'll show up,
there's three.
The next day you show up,
there's four or five.
And how do you get the space
for the camp?
We do it at schools, parks,
rec centers, gyms.
We've even done it
on the large stadiums, as well.
You have to pay rent
for that space?
Absolutely.
You have to pay for the rent
at some locations.
How long is a class?
Each class is 60 minutes.
So, what we have
is a fitness camp.
So, basically what happens
is kids sign up
for either 8, 16, or 24 classes.
They're $99 to $250,
and they can earn
different-colored dog tags
as they promote
through the ranks.
So, it's kind of like karate,
but with Bounce Boot Camp,
we have privates, captains,
sergeant, majors, colonels,
and junior generals, as well.
That's very cute.
We want to actually license this
out across the country
and put Bounce Boot Camps in
every single city and state.
What's your background?
My background is fitness.
I'm a children's fitness
specialist.
So, then, tell us
about the revenues.
Great question.
So, right now,
in 16 months of sales,
we did $43,000 in sales.
And that's working
one day a week.
What about the last month,
Thomas?
Is there a trending
month over month?
So, the last month,
in our actual sales,
we've roughly been
about 2,500 bucks.
O'LEARY: Thomas, if I want to
set up mine in Boston,
what does it cost?
The business is $40,000, okay?
Whoa.
It's $40,000.
For us, it's $20,000 is the cost
for all of the equipment,
the trailer.
HERJAVEC: But you haven't sold
any yet, right?
That is correct.
It's an idea.
And what I --
CUBAN: Thomas,
I love what you're doing,
and I always respect
entrepreneurs -- their grind --
because most don't have
the fortitude
just to fight through it.
Sure thing.
Right.
So, you said you're working
still one day a week?
Correct.
What are you doing
the other six days?
I do pharmaceutical sales.
You've got
a full-time job.
You have at least one daughter,
right?
Right.
I do have twin boys.
Okay, so you got three of 'em,
right?
So you're caught in that
entrepreneur's dilemma.
Do I keep my job
'cause I got bills to pay,
or do I go for it?
right.
And $30,000 is not enough
for you to go for it,
and it's not enough for you
to really commit
to doing something bigger
by hiring people.
Right.
And so because
you're in between,
as much as I love the concept
and I respect what you're doing
and just the effort
you've put in,
I don't think
you're ready to be a business
that takes on
an investor yet.
And so for that reason,
I'm out.
GREINER: You know what?
I personally think
really clever,
very creative, great idea.
Thank you.
What you should be doing
instead of thinking franchises
is really making it
something solid, year-round,
that works for you
in Arizona.
But because
you're not there yet,
I don't think there's something
to invest in at the moment.
Okay. Okay.
And so for that reason,
I'm out.
Thomas, I think your business
model is flawed, okay?
I don't think
this is gonna work.
Might as well get the truth
from me.
That's why they call me
Mr. Wonderful.
I'd love to hear
what you have to say about it.
That's not true.
But here's the problem.
You're gonna try and sell me
this for $40,000.
The guy next door to me
doesn't have to pay that much
to buy the same thing.
There's nothing proprietary
about this.
I disagree with that.
It takes time to put
this program together,
and that's exactly
what I've done.
So when you say it's flawed, I
disagree with you, respectfully.
Had you sold 10 of them
already
and convinced people
to pay you $40,000,
that would have been
more impressive to me.
I want the proof,
my friend.
You don't have it.
I'm out.
I appreciate that.
Thomas, I just think
it's a little too soon.
Before you go out,
this is a start-up,
and how great would it be to be
able to be in the ground floor?
And I'm not asking
for a large investment.
I'm really not.
I'm asking for $30,000.
That's not
a very large investment.
I'm asking for a little bit of
time, a little bit of patience,
and I'll do the work.
I'm not asking you to work.
I don't need any of you to step
outside of what you do right now
and work for me.
That's not why I'm here.
I respect
how hard you're working.
But I don't see how I can invest
today to help grow my money.
I wish you all the best,
my friend.
I'm out.
JOHN: Tom, we have to be honest
with you.
You know,
you have a noble cause.
You're getting kids
off the couch.
I don't know when the last time
I heard a kid say,
"I'm gonna go out in the street
and play football."
absolutely.
But at this point,
the business model doesn't work.
I have to be out.
Oh, man.
Man.
Thomas, you got all
the best advice in the world.
Just take that advice
and run with it.
No, you're right.
You're right, absolutely.
Good luck, man.
Thanks for the opportunity.
I'll be back.
Thank you, guys.
O'LEARY:
It's too expensive.
You could buy one of those
for $3,000 more than --
he knows that the franchise
model hasn't worked out yet.
Look, the guy's
a great entrepreneur.
He's just got to go out there
and hustle.
I didn't see anybody write
a check.
We'll be back.
We're still gonna try to fight
childhood obesity,
and we're still gonna grow
Bounce Boot Camp
into a big brand.
So, hey, you win some,
you lose some.
I still feel like we won.
NARRATOR: Next up
is a forensic pathologist
with a prescription
for a common household malady.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Jim Lewis.
I'm from Chester County,
Pennsylvania,
and my company's name
is the Wall Doctor Rx.
Sharks, I'm asking for $150,000
for 10% equity of my business.
Sharks, I'm a wall-ologist,
a doctor of walls.
And I've created one of the
greatest products in the world,
Wall Rx.
But, look, enough talk.
Let's see what I've got.
First, you need a hole.
[ laughs ]
Now, in order to fix that hole,
you need all of this...
And all of this.
Oh, and don't forget this.
Dry as a bone.
Spackle.
Or you simply need this --
wall rx.
Let's see how it works.
First, like any good surgeon,
let us prepare the surface.
Surface prepped.
[ laughter ]
Now, take your disc
and place it over your hole.
Now, take your frame
with your special compound
and place it over the disk.
Press and spread
to desired smoothness.
Done.
In 24 to 48 hours,
it will look like this.
Remove your frame.
Huh.
Wow.
And sand.
Oh, you have to sand it?
No tools, no skills,
and no mess.
Now, who wants to come up
and give it a try?
I want to touch it.
Want to knock a hole
in the wall, Lori,
or you want to just touch it?
Yeah.
I'm gonna do both.
Please do.
Okay.
I would hit it right there.
There you go.
JOHN: There you go.
Okay.
Now, take your disc.
Pull the paper
from your disc.
Okay.
Place it over the hole.
Now take
your special compound.
Okay.
And place it
over the disc.
Press.
Easy.
Done. That's it.
Pretty cool.
Wall doctor,
what happens if the hole
is four inches in diameter?
Oh, Mr. Wonderful,
that's a great --
that's a great question.
You get
the four-inch hole repair.
HERJAVEC:
I've never -- I've never seen
a product like this,
so what's proprietary
about it?
Is it the compound
that you put together?
We have three full patents
on it.
Jim, are you --
are you an engineer?
Are you a chemist?
Are you a doctor?
Oh, no, I'm a real doctor.
I'm a forensic pathologist.
So, Jim, for a living,
you see dead people.
I do.
All right.
So, Jim,
let me ask you something.
Three years ago,
you created this?
Three years ago.
So, what are your sales?
Right now, I've sold a couple.
Uh, we sold 80,000.
Okay.
That's not a couple.
What is your gross sales?
Our gross sales was $600,000.
Oh.
Wow!
Jim, do they have a projection
for next year?
Between a half million
to a million.
Whoa.
But I realize,
you can drown in success.
I've had people come to us
and asking us to put it
in their stores.
Matter of fact, I just met with
the largest retailer on Earth,
and they want it.
And I told 'em,
"I can't do it this year
because I don't have
enough capital."
I've got to automate
my process more,
and if I did it, I would
just take all my inventory.
I would just be -- I would fail.
What does it sell for?
We don't even know.
They're selling
between $6.99 and $9.99.
And what does it cost you
to make?
$2.50 -- $2 to $2.50.
What are you gonna use
the money for?
We're gonna take all the money
and use it for buying machinery
to automate our process.
'cause you're a doctor.
Do you still practice?
I have two full-time jobs.
Wall doctor
and regular doctor.
That's pretty hard to do,
doctor.
I mean, think about it.
If you're gonna grow
this company
and start servicing
the largest retailer on Earth,
either you're gonna do it,
or you're gonna hire
somebody else to do it.
You understand, when you jump
into the big leagues,
you have to build a real company
to support that.
Absolutely.
I'd like to make you
an interesting offer.
I have a lot of connections
internationally in this space,
so I'll give you the $150,000,
no equity.
You can keep
the United States sales.
You give me exclusive rights
for this product,
whatever you sell it for today,
to Lowe's --
let's say
you're selling at $2.
I'll buy it at $2 from you
and sell it
to the rest of the world.
Wow.
Doctor,
I'll make you an offer.
I'll give you $150,000
for 15%.
With one contingency.
I want to license
this technology.
I want to give it to a company
that's global,
that has distribution,
manufacturing,
and handles
all the logistics.
You stay being a doctor,
and you get a check every month.
You're on the cusp
of a huge business.
Do you want to be
filthy rich,
or do you want to actually sell
packages of tape?
Which is it?
Oh, I want to be filthy rich
like everyone else.
Ahh,
now you're my kind of guy.
I like Kevin's offer.
My offer's just like Kevin's.
I want to outsource
manufacturing and license it,
except I'm gonna give you
twice the money.
Thank you, Daymond.
Thank you so much.
My offer is $300,000,
twice what you asked for,
for 20% equity.
We will take it
right to QVC,
and right to
an infomercial spot,
because that's where I think
you will make this brand
and this product known globally
with lightning speed.
Whoa.
Whoa, this is, uh...
Wow.
Those are your options.
What is your decision?
NARRATOR: Jim has four offers
on the table.
Robert has offered $150,000
for zero equity,
but he wants
the exclusive rights
to sell the product
internationally.
Kevin has offered $150,000
for 15% of the company,
contingent on
licensing the product
to outsource all manufacturing
and distribution.
Daymond has the same contingency
as Kevin,
but has offered $300,000
for 15%,
and Lori has offered $300,000
but for 20% of the company.
Those are your options.
What is your decision?
Now I know why they call you
sharks and not guppies.
Well, I'm thinking,
I like your deal, Robert,
because the rest of the world
can be taken care of,
and I don't have a problem
with that.
Robert takes a platform
that we all are interested
in taking advantage of, as well.
O'LEARY: When I go to a global
manufacturer, distributor,
logistics company,
they don't want to see
any territory excluded.
GREINER: And when I go to
an infomercial company,
they want to have
all possibilities open to them.
They want to go global.
So Robert's offer is effectively
radioactive waste.
We have not heard
from Mr. Cuban yet.
CUBAN: Daymond says
he's the people's advocate.
I'm the entrepreneur's advocate,
so I'm gonna go out,
and I'm here to answer
any questions, but I'm out.
Okay.
Robert, I want you and Lori
to work together.
Robert,
your deal is phenomenal.
I need you two
to work together.
Doc, I love you, but --
please, please, you got to come
together with this, please.
I just --
I love you, but...
My wife would kill me
if I said no to you,
and my wife would kill me
so you've got to come together
with this.
Please --
so, are you saying no
to Kevin and I?
I -- yes.
Don't say
that you're dead to me.
I would love to have you and you
together.
We know you want that.
I want that.
But --
so, now, now,
you guys got to work it out.
You've got to work it out.
Somebody's got to --
I can't do it. it would be
a stupid move for me.
I have in my mind
what I know
will be the successful
marketing structure for you.
I need to bring it
to my infomercial partners,
and they have to have
global rights.
Understood.
Was your counter to give us
some equity into it?
The counter was to get you
two together,
and what do I need to get you
two together?
Doctor, they don't want to work
together.
Robert...
We got a deal.
No, no, no, no.
Now, wait.
Don't change your mind now.
Hang on, my friend.
Oh, Doc!
What?
Hang on, my friend.
Whoa.
I don't want to be your cousin
at the dance.
My offer didn't change
all the way through,
but you countered that
you only wanted to take my deal
if you got Lori into it.
Honestly, Robert,
are you declining?
Don't -- now, don't --
please don't decline.
Please, please stay in the deal,
please.
Will you take the deal?
[ sighs ]
You know, let's do it.
I'm there. Let's do it.
I'm there, man.
Do I hear a yes?
Yes!
Can I get a "yes"?
Robert,
he said yes before!
All right.
Man, this is great.
Thank you so much.
It was a little confusing there
for a while.
No, no, no.
To nobody but you, Robert.
One other thing,
you are dead to me.
[ laughs ]
Thank you so much.
Look,
I think he's very clever.
A lot of entrepreneurs
don't realize,
there's other markets
around the world.
This lets him focus
on what he has.
I don't think
that was clever.
Yeah!
I was trying to do something
to get her in on the deal,
whatever it took
for those two to work together.
That one could have been,
like, Batman and Robin.
We could have had
United States covered
and the rest of the world.
I'm heartbroken,
but my heart was mended
when Robert said,
yes, we had a deal.
NARRATOR: Last season,
three friends from Rhode Island
made a deal with Robert and Mark
for their high-protein
nut Butters, Nuts 'N More.
You guys got a deal.
All right.
[ applause ]
NARRATOR:
Let's see how they're doing now.
Morning, LeAnn.
Since "Shark Tank,"
business has been nuts.
And more.
Prior to "Shark Tank,"
we had $100,000 in sales
in 5 months.
7 months later, we have exceeded
$1 million in sales.
We were doing $2,500 a week.
Now we're doing $2,500 a day.
That's
a lot of peanut butter.
As Rhode Islanders,
we have a great opportunity
to create local jobs.
Manufacturing has been gone
for a long time in this state,
but we're bringing it back.
We've grown
to over 12 employees,
expanded to a 10,000-square foot
state-of-the-art
manufacturing facility,
and have been picked up
by two of the nation's
top supplement distributors.
Mark and Robert
have been fantastic.
They have been great mentors in
helping us build our business.
Robert recently visited us
at the largest fitness
trade show in the country.
Having him there,
showing his support,
was such an unbelievable feeling
for us.
Come on, guys.
We got 230 orders to get done
by the end of the day.
Let's go!
Before "Shark Tank,"
we were only in 32 stores.
Now we're in over 600 stores,
and we just locked in
Whole Foods.
We're looking at being
in over 32,000 stores.
We're projecting $5 million
to $6 million in the next year.
Having the opportunity
to be your own boss
and run your own company
is everything we ever wanted.
"Shark Tank" has really made
our dreams come true.
ALL: Nuts 'N More!
[ cheering ]
NARRATOR:
Next up is an entrepreneur
from Washington, D.C.,
with his answer to a nationwide
security problem.
Hello, sharks.
My name is C.J. Isakow
from our nation's capital,
Washington, D.C.
My company is eyebloc,
and I'm seeking $50,000
for 10% of my company,
because, sharks,
Americans are being watched!
They're watching you
with cameras
that are already in your home,
in your office, in your school,
even in your bedroom.
They're watching you
through your computer.
That's right.
People can remotely access
your computer
and watch you
through this camera.
Don't believe me?
Robert,
you're in I.T. security.
You can vouch for this.
Absolutely true.
Even the most modest of hackers
can take over your laptop
and control the camera.
For proof,
just turn on the evening news.
There's beauty queens
being blackmailed.
Some creep was taking pictures
of her in her bedroom
in her most private moments
and was blackmailing her.
Even our own government
is overstepping their bounds.
Sharks, I love my country.
I love our freedom!
And this violates
America's very core,
but don't worry.
There's a solution, sharks.
Eyebloc,
the webcam privacy shield.
Designed to fit any device
and cover the camera,
ensuring no one can spy on you.
Let me show you how it works.
Let's say some hacker's gotten
into your computer,
and he's watching you.
It's really sick.
But guess what.
He's watching you,
taking a little too much
interest in your home,
and then...boom!
Eyebloc'd!
Amazing!
Boom goes the dynamite!
You want to see it again?
Did you catch it?
Did we catch it?
Boom!
Oh!
Eyebloc'd!
So, which one of you sharks
is ready to step up,
protect America --
actually, protect the world --
and take a bite
out of cybercrime?
[ laughs ]
Robert,
how big a problem is this?
Yeah, is that true?
Absolutely.
It happens all the time.
It's very difficult
to turn it off
for the average consumer.
C.J., you want me
to give you $50,000
for that little piece of crap?
Yeah.
[ laughs ]
let me ask you a question.
how many of you guys
have ever been naked
in front of your computer,
raise your hand?
Wait a minute.
ISAKOW: Have you ever been naked
in front of your computer?
GREINER: Daily.
Yes or no, Mr. Wonderful?
[ laughs ]
So, tell us about the business,
C.J.
We're a new business.
We're very, you know,
rapid growth.
Two months ago,
this thing didn't exist,
and now I'm getting orders
from people in the military.
I'm getting --
so, how much has
the total orders have been?
45.
Wait, 45 units?
45 --
45,000?
No. Come on.
You said fast-growing company.
So far,
I'm averaging about one a day.
Wow!
It could double to two a day.
Come on.
[ laughs ]
what if it went to three a day?
How much are you selling it for,
C.J.?
Great question. $9.99.
$9.99?
[ laughs ]
Plus $4
shipping and handling.
I'm making 10 bucks.
I've sold over $600 worth
on Amazon.
Wow!
C.J., you know why
it's only been 45 units?
'cause I could take
a piece of gum --
I could take
a post-it note.
You're right.
I could take anything
and just pop it over there.
Mark, you're right.
This is my competition
right here, right here.
Do you want this?
Do you want this
all over your laptop?
You put it on your laptop,
you forget about it.
You're unprotected again.
You know what?
I'm not gonna lose
post-it notes.
There are always
gonna be more.
That thing, I'm gonna lose.
Let me show it to you, Mark.
Let me show you,
'cause it's really high quality.
Yeah, hand 'em out, C.J.,
please.
Red, white, and blue.
I'll go blue.
I'll go white.
Thank you.
ISAKOW:
Don't lose those.
I've already sold those
on Amazon.
[ laughs ]
So --
I like this guy.
Here's the thing.
I invested 5 grand
in an aluminum mold
so I can get them priced down
to $1.25.
A steel mold, and that's part of
what I want the investment for,
will get the price down
to under 25 cents.
So, if you see on the back
is our logo,
and it'll be more prominent
in the mold.
You could use it
as home plate
in your cockroach
baseball league.
[ laughs ]
Cockroach baseball league.
It looks like home plate.
I have a huge problem
with one thing -- the price.
You said you were selling this
for $9.99?
Yeah.
Honestly,
this, to me, a buck.
I'm sorry
to crush your dreams.
Think about car alarms
in the 1980s.
Car alarms in the 1980s,
everyone bought car alarms to
keep people out of their cars.
Everyone's
gonna be buying eyeblocs
to keep them
out of their private lives.
I know, but I think
that they can also think
of a million other ways
to also put a block on.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
C.J., there's definitely
a market
to protect kids, especially,
from their webcams.
Yeah, absolutely.
I don't think this is it.
I'm out.
Okay.
Well, C.J., Robert is one of
the top ten cybercrime experts
in the world.
If he's not in, there's no way
I'm even gonna think about it.
I'm out.
Okay.
Look, we could make fun.
You're selling fear,
right?
But it's not really
a company.
It's just a product.
I'm out.
Okay.
Mr. Wonderful, I think the other
big opportunity here
is I know you love licensing --
yeah, yeah,
you know, C.J. --
so you could license --
these are going to start to be
built-in --
I'm also a historian.
I'm gonna give you a little
story that you're gonna enjoy
and you're gonna learn from.
Okay.
[ laughs ]
Oh, good.
I love his stories.
In the days when there wasn't
any internet,
and we just had cities
and forts and castles...
Yeah.
...The universal
sign of distress
was an upside down flag.
When bad things
were happening,
they'd turn their flag
upside down and hoist it up.
Everybody around them knew,
"whoa, this is bad news.
Something's really bad
in there."
okay.
I think it's time for you
to turn the flag upside down.
[ laughs ]
Oh, man.
I'm out.
All right.
I hope to prove you wrong.
Please keep it for your kids.
Thank you.
See you, bud.
It's an interesting idea,
you know,
'cause you are being watched
all the time,
everywhere you go.
It's pretty sick that we're
being watched all the time.
That is absolute crap
on a stick.
ISAKOW: These sharks,
they just live in a bubble.
I can't believe
they don't understand
that this is a real
privacy issue for real people.
I mean, what's -- what's going
through their head?
NARRATOR:
Next into the tank
is a couple
with an affordable solution
for all those digital photos
stacking up on our smartphones.
Hi, sharks.
My name is Brian Whiteman,
and this is my baby mama,
Julie.
We're from Chatsworth,
California,
and today we are seeking
$150,000
for 20% of our company,
Groovebook.
Billions of photos are taken
every day from smartphones.
Who doesn't have a phone
with hundreds,
if not thousands, of photos?
What do people do with all
the photos they've taken?
Absolutely nothing.
For just $2.99 a month,
including shipping and handling,
the Groovebook app
allows you to choose
up to 100 photos every month
from your smartphone
and create a beautiful, bound
photo book in just minutes.
Each month, your Groovebook
gets delivered to you
with an exciting new cover.
Your photos
are automatically stamped
with the date and location
so you will never forget.
They're perforated,
for easy removal,
and 4x6,
which is the perfect size
for framing and sharing.
Who is that?
Is that you?
Is that you as a little one?
Why, it is.
Aw!
You had hair?
GREINER: [ laughs ]
I have never seen you with hair.
Groovebook will save you
time and money
from printing out your photos
at the store
and on ink cartridges
at home.
Forget those expensive
photo books.
They'll take you hours
online
and then charge you an arm and
a leg for printing and shipping.
Groovebook is the answer.
So, which one of you sharks
is ready
to get your groove on...
With Groovebook?
Oy.
Now my beautiful wife
of 15 years
is gonna give each one of you
your own custom Groovebook.
Oh, wow.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
CUBAN: Thanks, Julie.
Okay.
So, Brian?
BRIAN: Yes.
What do you charge me
for the book?
You get that entire book
for $2.99 a month,
including shipping and handling.
Wow.
That's a really great price.
Thank you.
How are you doing it
for that low of a price?
What does it cost you
to make the book?
It costs me $2.30
to make the book.
So,
you have a very small profit.
We have a 70-cents profit margin
per book.
Wow!
Do you have any sales?
Yes, we do.
Okay.
We have 18,000 paid subscribers
in the last 8 months.
Good for you.
Oh.
BRIAN:
18,000 paid subscribers.
So, what are you making
per month?
Do the math for me.
Well, right now,
we're not making any money.
We need to get to 30,000
customers to break even.
After we get to
30,000 customers,
we make 70 cents
every book.
Why aren't you making money now?
Because our overhead's
$21,000 a month.
Who's making these, though?
We manufacture the books
internally ourselves
in our print shop.
Now, why haven't you --
or have you tried another price?
Because we want everybody
in America
to be able to afford
this book,
and we didn't want to have
any excuses --
come on, guys.
I mean, look --
nobody in America can get it
if you close the business.
GREINER: Right.
No.
Yeah, everybody in America?
When I hear that,
it's just, like, "be real."
how much have you guys invested
in this company?
I've invested $400,000.
Oh.
HERJAVEC: Wow.
BRIAN: Yeah.
Wow. Wow.
If you didn't own
a printing business,
if I took this book and took it
to another commercial printer,
would my costs be
what you're charging today?
It'd be higher.
No, because I've developed
proprietary software
and specialized equipment --
Was Mark right?
would it be higher?
It would be higher.
But you understand
the problem with that?
Yes, yes.
I need your other business
to stay in business
with this business.
You know, I don't think
you ever explained
why we have the groove
in the side of the book.
One night
in Brian's frustration --
he was working on this
for months
trying to figure out
how to get this book flexible
so that we can mail it bulk
through the U.S. postal service.
He was beating with a pen
at the spine of the book.
He was so mad and frustrated.
Then he came to me, he's,
like, "Julie, Julie, wake up!"
and he showed me the photo book,
and it was all damaged,
and I said to him,
"What are you showing me?"
and he said,
"Look, it's flexing.
It's flexing.
I have the answer."
we will now
be able to ship the book
at about 80 cents apiece.
So because this book
is flexible, and this is --
we have a patent pending
on the groove inside the book.
Because it's flexible,
I'm able to mail it
for 82 cents.
So, that is the value
proposition in your business.
So, if you changed the postage
because of the new binding,
what does it cost?
It'll go up $3 to $4.
So, anyone
that tries to compete with us
is gonna have $4
just in postage.
And you're saying you can
protect this groove in it
because it's patent pending?
Yes.
CUBAN:
That's what I'm saying,
that's the most valuable asset
that you have.
this is really amazing.
Brian, can I --
can I ask you a question
as a potential investor?
Mm-hmm.
Would you consider raising
your price by a dollar?
Yes,
we would be open to that.
CUBAN: See, I think that's
the wrong business altogether.
I say Groovebook
as a service...
Mm-hmm.
...Okay, that starts
to get interesting.
So, I can go to Shutterfly
and say,
"Shutterfly, you can't offer
something like this.
You have high shipping."
Right, their average book
is $30 a book.
Ours is $2.99.
Forget the pricing.
I want to make it a service
so that --
the problem is you don't own
that customer.
What's that?
You don't own that customer.
HERJAVEC: No, no,
but Mark is dead-on.
Mark is --
what you have here --
you don't own the customer
anymore.
This is a unique act,
the groove and the ability to
ship and create these pictures
so inexpensively through you.
Entrepreneurs lie to themselves
all the time.
They get visions of grandeur,
and here you are giving us
those visions of grandeur
by saying you want this for
every home in America, right?
Get over that.
Wouldn't you rather
be able to say to all those --
all those applications that
you're competing with right now,
"Nyah, nyah, nyah, nyah, nyah,
I've got a groove
and I can ship this for 82 cents
and you can't"?
But if you want to offer this
to all your customers,
I'm gonna give you
an interface,
and I'm gonna charge you 7 cents
a picture.
You become a commercial printer
in his scenario.
No, no, better yet,
all you do is you become
a money collector.
I think Mark's dead-on.
There are
so many applications,
as more photo sites come up
and people upload to them.
You've done something
none of them can do
at that price point.
Yes! Okay, guys,
I'm gonna make you an offer.
I'll give you $150,000
for 100% of the rights
to sell Groovebook
as a service through
your commercial printer
to everybody else.
You keep 100% of the Groovebook
subscription service.
I want to license this
as a service,
and then I can go to everybody
and say,
"Look, 82 cents to ship this,
$2.30 to print it.
I'm gonna mark it up
by 3 bucks."
if Shutterfly, Flickr,
whoever it is -- Picasa --
this way you can offer it
to all your customers.
Brian,
I think it's a phenomenal idea.
Thank you.
But this business
does not exist
without your commercial
printing business.
Your costs are artificially low
because of your other business.
I have a problem with that.
If I get into business
with Groovebook
and the commercial
printing business goes away,
what do I do?
Like, I -- it's so symbiotic.
They're so related.
One doesn't exist
without the other.
That's why your price point
is so low
because you're able to do that.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you.
Robert made a point.
I'm a partner in Groovebook.
You go out of business or
you decide to raise the prices
or anything else happens
with your commercial printer,
I have a problem.
I'm out.
Would you consider selling me
the whole thing?
At the right price.
Well, you've put a value on it
of $750,000, right?
Correct.
Would you consider selling
the whole thing?
And by the way, Brian,
that's what you walked in here
asking for.
I gave you what you wanted.
Yes, but we'd like to have
some upside on that, also.
So, Mark, I'd like to just
clarify a little bit more,
one more time, please.
CUBAN: Sure.
So, in essence,
I'm paying you 150k
to be the right to be,
hopefully, your commercial
printing company's
largest Groovebook supplier.
HERJAVEC:
So, Brian, Julie,
you've got $150,000
for a pure licensing deal.
You keep 100% of your business.
Okay.
The other offer from Kevin
is the full value
of what you put on your company,
$750,000,
for 100% of the business.
Two completely different
avenues.
Totally different.
So, so --
I think we'd like
to counter Kevin's offer.
Yeah, we'd like to counter
Kevin's offer,
and we think the company
at this stage of the game
is worth $6 million.
Oh!
Wow.
NARRATOR:
Two sharks are out.
Brian and Julie
have two offers on the table --
one from Mark for $150,000
for the licensing rights
to Groovebook
and one from Kevin,
who has offered $750,000
to buy 100% of the company.
Two completely different
avenues.
Totally different.
So, so --
I think we'd like to counter
Kevin's offer.
Yeah. We'd like to counter
Kevin's offer,
and we think the -- the company
at this stage of the game
is worth $6 million.
Oh!
Wow.
But you valued it
at $750,000.
Because we want to be
a part of the upside.
If you don't want to sell
100% of it, I understand,
but you can't take the price
and multiply it by 6
to sell control.
Nobody would do that to you.
Sure, they can.
They can do whatever they want.
No, but it won't happen.
The transaction won't occur.
Are you saying yes or no
to their $6 million?
No, I won't pay $6 million for
it, and you knew I wouldn't.
Is there some middle ground?
And you don't want us to have
any skin in the game
and grow it with you?
well, I do, but I'm just --
I asked you simply to understand
you as an entrepreneur,
where your head's at.
Do you want to sell out?
Is there a price
that makes sense?
The answer is no. I get it.
We want to have more skin
in the game. We --
how much skin in the game
do you want, my friend?
I'd like to have
at least 50%.
You want me to grow
the business.
We are so passionate --
that's why my deal was perfect
for you, then.
JULIE: You have to understand,
Brian --
your deal is -- is --
it makes a lot of sense,
but with yours,
I'd like to have a little bit
of skin in the game
rather than 100% royalty because
I'm manufacturing for you.
What do you think 50%
of Groovebook is worth today?
Kevin.
[ indistinct conversation ]
it's worth $375,000.
and it's a no-brainer.
All we want to do is we want to
make a win-win situation.
So you would sell --
okay, you would sell
50% of Groovebook for $375,000?
Listen, we're gonna --
Mark and I are just gonna step
aside for one second, okay?
GREINER: If you'll do that --
HERJAVEC: What are you --
if you'll do that,
then I will give you the deal.
You do not want to do a $375,000
for 50%. You don't.
$375,000 for 50%, but I don't
want to be competing with Mark.
Yeah, I'll jump in on her
with that deal.
I don't want to compete
with Mark,
because I don't want there to be
all these other people out there
using the same technology.
If you get the patent,
I would be willing to give you
the $375,000,
and if Robert
wants to go in on it --
happy to go in with it.
Great, at 50% -- 25%/25%.
But the whole business.
No licensing to somebody else.
Right.
You got to control
the whole thing.
Not doing what Mark is saying.
And if you'll do it right now,
we can have a deal.
Brian, you said you'd sell 50%
for $375,000.
Will you do the deal?
Hell, no.
Are you kidding?
He's smarter than that.
O'LEARY: Okay, guys.
No, no, no, no, hang on.
Hang on.
Maybe that's
a better deal.
Lori made an offer.
I'd like to hear their offer.
Okay,
let me say what we decided.
$150,000 for a license
to the name and the software
and the ability to offer it
as a service.
80% for Kevin and I,
20% for you,
so you share in the upside.
What we're gonna be
is the one-off guys.
Mm-hmm.
So when someone says, "I have
375 pictures on my camera.
"I don't want a subscription.
I want a place where I can go
and buy it."
You'll be
the owner of Groovebook
and the Groovebook
subscription service.
We'll be Groovebook
for all one-off applications
or purchases.
Okay.
HERJAVEC: But, Brian,
you realize that --
that is a really bad thing
to do.
He's giving an alternative
to all your customers
that you're trying to build
a business to.
They don't have to be
subscribers.
He's building a competitive
one-off business.
It's kind of like the movie
"there will be blood."
[ laughter ]
You know, the guy had the oil,
and, you know, he didn't
want to give up the oil
to Daniel Day-Lewis,
so Daniel Day-Lewis
bought the house next to him.
He dug underneath,
and he sucked his oil well dry.
GREINER: Exactly.
You realize,
I'm a subscriber.
I'm about to sign up
for Groovebook.
I look on Flickr, and I say,
"Oh, I don't need to subscribe.
I can do it one time."
so now you have two sharks,
Kevin and Mark,
who want to give you $150,000
for 80% of
the non-subscription business.
And then you have another offer
with two sharks
who want to give you $375,000
for 50% of your business,
and they help grow
everything with you.
What are you going to do?
Well, I think we've done
an excellent job
growing it ourselves
to 18,000 subscribers
in a short period of time.
I think the better deal...
...Would be to go
with Mark and Mr. Wonderful
because 100%
of growing it ourselves
plus an additional
20% of revenue
that you guys will work at
I think
is a win/win situation.
And I'm all about making
win/win situations.
Do you accept their offer?
Yes, we do.
CUBAN: Let's go to work!
Congratulations.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
Thank you. Thank you.
So exciting.
It's very cool.
GREINER: Congratulations.
Thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
Oh, my God!
Wow!
Whoo!
Dang!
They're still in love.
Whoo!